[Music]
the bottom line is that we simply do not
have sufficient evidence to charge
anyone with a crime related to Prince's
death Carver County attorney mark Metz
announced at a press conference on
Thursday that no criminal charges will
be filed following the two-year
investigation into the death of Prince
Mets called the investigation quote
painstaking and thorough and said
evidence suggests Prince thought he was
taking vicodin not fentanyl on the night
he overdosed nothing in the evidence
suggests that Prince knowingly ingested
fentanyl adding evidence also suggests
he took counterfeit vicodin laced with
fentanyl in all likelihood Prince had no
idea he was taking a counterfeit pill
that could kill him authorities do not
know where the music icon got the
counterfeit pills there is no reliable
evidence showing how Prince obtained the
counterfeit vicodin laced with fentanyl
or who else may have had a role in
delivering the counterfeit vicodin to
Prince Mets also announced that a thirty
thousand dollar civil suit was settled
with dr. Schulenburg a doctor who saw
Prince before his death met said that
although the doctor prescribed Prince
percocet in Prince's longtime friend
Kirk Johnson's name percocet is not what
killed the late singer a statement
provided by dr. schulenburg lawyer
Amy Connors said in part quote dr.
schulenburg decided to settle with the
United States regarding alleged civil
claims in order to avoid the expence
delay and unknown outcome of litigation
he made no admission of facts nor
liability and deny
any such liability in his nearly 20
years of practice
dr. schulenburg has provided the highest
level of care to as many patients and
has earned a reputation for being a
caring and responsible physician Prince
was found dead in an elevator at his
Paisley Park Estate in Minnesota on
April 21st 2016 he was 57 years old
[Music]